Ja, ich hab keine Snare auf meinen Headphones. Uh, auf die Eins steig ich ein. Ja, ja, Mikrofon check one two. One two check, one two check, Bruder, das ist ein Brett. Willkommen zum Potwal-Uno mit Sebastian Teitzler und Florian Willinger. Digga. Hey, hallo und herzlich willkommen zu dieser fantastischen neuen Ausgabe von Das Podcast UFO. Nicht allein sitze ich hier in diesem heißen Raume, nein, mir gegenüber sitzt er, die Kiez-Legende Stefan Tietzel. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, meine Damen und Herren, zu einer neuen Folge des Podcast UFO, Folge 267. Das ist 267. Korrekt. Ich muss immer nachdenken bei grossen Zahlen, was zuerst kommt, die Einserstelle oder die Zehnerstelle. Wir sind so grosse Zahlen, vielleicht hätten wir auch irgendwie ab 250 sagen müssen, 250 A, 250 B, dass man da nicht in so grosse Zahlen reinkommt. Oder rückwärts dann wieder. Und alle denken dann so, weißt du, wie man gezählt hat vor Christus Geburt. Immer so 2048, 2007, wait, what's happening? Es dauert noch 2000 Jahre, aber irgendwas wird passieren. Irgendwas wird passieren. Und bei uns, bei Folge 250, dann 249 zu machen und 248 sind alle so, wow, what is happening? Aber das ist eigentlich eine geniale Idee, runterzuzählen. Wenn du schon weißt, du willst nur, also wir haben ja damals vor acht Jahren gesagt, wir machen ungefähr so 4000 Folgen. Das heißt, ab 2000 können wir da runterzählen und dann Leute sagen dann vielleicht auch, ja, zählt man im Zweierschritt weiter. So was in der Richtung passt schon. Ja, weil ich finde, wenn man es bei 2000 dann so macht, hat auch niemand Angst. Also kurz erstmal mal, ist ein bisschen so zu wissen, die Welt geht irgendwann unter, aber ich werde es nicht mehr miterleben. Die Chance, dass ich in 2000 Folgen noch Podcast-Ufo-Hörer bin, ist gleich null. Es ist ja besser zu wissen, dass sie in fünf Jahren aufhört, als immer Angst zu haben, dass es aufhört. Das ist wie wenn die Welt jetzt runterzählen würde. Das ist, glaube ich, auch mit diesen Klimawandelsachen, das ist so, ja, in hundert Jahren geht es bergab und du so gut. Ja, wir haben ja auch mal gesagt, wir hören niemals auf, in einer der letzten Ausgaben des Podcast-Ufos, was uns vielleicht auch nochmal zum Verhängnis wird. Ja, wir haben da anwaltlich, wir haben da diverse Anwälte eingeschaltet, um zu fragen, ob man das so sagen kann, ob das ein Versprechen ist, das man geben kann. Aber es ist ja in einem satirischen Kontext gefallen. Ja, das ist wie wenn man so sagt, alles ist gut, so, und es ist halt nicht alles technisch gesehen, nicht alles gut. Es gibt Dinge auf dieser Welt, die sind schlecht, gewisse Joghurtbecher sind zu klein, ich will keinen Namen nennen, aber nicht alles ist gut auf dieser... Gut, du hast dich entschieden. Nee, ich glaube, das kann man sagen, das ist rechtlich schon, der Prozess ist schon durch. Bruchzwerge sind zu klein, als so ein fetter Richter. Du hast dich entschieden, diesen Deckel, diesen Joghurt verschmierten Deckel aufzumachen und wir alle wissen nicht, wohin das führt. Bist du einer, der dann auch die Fruchtzwerge einfriert, der sagt, sommerlich esse ich alles anders, da werden Früchte püriert und Fruchtzwerge eingefroren? Auf gar keinen Fall. Ich hasse das. Ich finde das auch schwierig, weil es ist ja nicht dafür gemacht und irgendwer hat mal entdeckt, das geht. Aber meine Frage ist jetzt auch an dich und das geht nicht nur für Fruchtzwerge, muss man alles machen, was auch geht. Das ist eine gute Frage, aber ich glaube, man muss sogar mehr machen als geht, weil ich habe damals bei den Fruchtzwergen, hatte ich dann diese Plastikstiele dabei, damit du die einfrieren kannst, aber dann habe ich die alle aufgegessen innerhalb von vier Minuten und dann hatte ich aber noch die Stiele. Länger ist, als ich dachte gerade, aber du hast so eine schöne Achterpackung in vier Minuten, das glaube ich eine ganze, also ich muss mich jetzt nicht für meine Zeit schämen, glaube ich, das war okay. Für so einen kleinen Kindermund, für so eine Kinderstopfluke, glaube ich, geht das. Aber ist jetzt auch kein Weltrekord. Nein, ist kein Weltrekord, damals war ich noch kein kompetitiver Esser, Das hat sich dann erst in der Pubertät entwickelt, dass die Zeiten dann in den Vordergrund gerückt sind. Aber dann hast du ja natürlich diese Plastikstühle und denkst dir, eigentlich unendliche Möglichkeiten. Ich kann die ja in beliebige Dinge reinstecken, die in das Gefrierfach tun und schauen, ob da ein Eisbei rauskommt. Monte. Monte, gut, sehr gut. Nee, ich glaube nicht sehr gut. Na klar, aber probier es aus, probier es zu Hause aus. Geht mal all in. Ja, Monte, auch mal so eine Packung Frischkäse, auch mal irgendwie eine Marmelade oder sowas. Wer sagt, dass man Marmelade nicht einfrieren kann? Ich glaube, Physik sagt an manchen Punkten, ich weiß es nicht, bei Marmelade bin ich mir nicht sicher, aber bei manchen Sachen kommt der große Herr, Frau Physik, steckt den großen Finger in die Luft und sagt, mhm, mhm, mhm, Entschuldigung, mhm, mhm, mhm, mhm, nicht mit mir, mhm, mhm, oder Wackelpudding zum Beispiel, Wackelpudding einfrieren, wer sagt, dass das nicht geht, jetzt wagst du zu viel, wer sagt, dass das nicht geht, Harald Lesch ärgert sich gerade rot und weiss und blau und schwarz, aber er kann nichts dagegen machen. Deswegen, auch mal geht diese Woche mal all in und steckt euch einfach mal euren Eisstiel überall rein. Warum denn hier, Gewürzgurken? Gewürzgurken? Wurstwasser, warum denn nicht? Ich bin eh der Meinung, dass diese Süssherb- Dichotomie überholt ist. Also das muss sich ändern. Zum Beispiel, dass man alles so Heissgetränke in Richtung Süss denkt. Ja, du hast dann Kaffee mit Zucker, du hast Tee mit Zucker, ja, du hast Zimt und Zucker, verstehst du? Watte und Zucker. Warum nicht mal in die Herbe-Richtung denken? Warum nicht mal eine Suppe so wie einen Tee konsumieren? Einfach Suppe in so eine Teetasse und nebenbei wegschlürfen, neben dem Film oder sowas. Warum wird Suppe mit Löffeln gegessen, Tee getrunken? Warum sagt man, alles Herbe wird gelöffelt, alles Süße wird getrunken? Du denkst ja gerade nur kurz, bis zu deinem begrenzten Sichtfeld. Was du gerade zum Beispiel vergessen hast bei deinen Ausführungen, ist, dass Suppen ja oft Stücke beinhalten. Aha, und du hast noch nie eine heiße Schokolade mit Marshmallows getrunken, oder was? Schachmat. Moment, aber ich habe doch noch irgendwo, ich kann meinen Läufer noch dazwischenziehen. Stefan Tietze, die Kamera ist bei sich eingefroren. Komisch, was ist da los im Hause Tietze? Ich bin sehr einfach Schachmat zu setzen neuerdings. Phase ist vorbei. Offensichtlich, nee, das kann ich Jan Gustavsson immer nicht antun, wenn ich das sage.
Nein, wir können es ja spoilern, du hast bei der aktuellen Staffel Zugzwang dem Rocket Beans Schachformat versagt. Ich bin in der ersten Runde ausgeschieden, lang und lang los. Die letzte Staffel dominiert hast, hoch angesehene Schachexperten dicht zu dem vielversprechendsten Schachtalent der Welt der Geschichte.
Der Welt der Geschichte.
Nicht der Welt, der Geschichte. Das beinhaltet auch andere Planeten und sonstige. Und ich muss auch immer darüber lachen, dass Leute die ganze Zeit schreiben, Jahrhunderttalent und so. Nein. Und machen das als Spaß und machen das gross. Und ich will immer dazwischen gehen und sagen, arroganterweise, nee, das Kompliment war noch krasser. Dieser Gag, den du gerade machst, der ist schon krass, aber die Realität war sogar noch krasser.
Du denkst, du würdest humoristisch übertreiben, aber du bist noch nicht mal beim Fakt. Du bist beim Jahrhundert. Wir reden aber nicht nur von hundert Jahren, sondern wir reden von der Geschichte.
Richtig, der Gesamtzeit. Gesamtzeit, inklusive Kreide, Jura, da war alles alles dabei, schmeißt alles in den Mix. Und du bist in der ersten Runde raus? Ja, okay, also raus, aber bei Schach kann es ganz schnell gehen, wenn du da eine Figur verwechselst, das Pony ist plötzlich der Pfarrer und dann ist alles für euch. Das Ding ist, ja, Schach ist ja sehr gnadenlos, ein Fehler und du bist raus, Wohingegen hat uns ja eins gelernt, die Fußball-Euro-Europameisterschaft 2020. Da wird heute noch der grosse Rückblick folgen. Wir gehen nochmal jedes Spiel durch. Auch aus der Gruppenphase, ja, ja, ja, werden wir nochmal alles Fehler auszüben. Albanien gegen Wales wird nochmal tot analysiert. Wenn ihr dachtet, ihr habt alles zwischen Bosnien und Mazedonien herausgefunden schon und alle taktischen Finessen. Nein, heute gibt es das große Antenneanstoss. Wir gehen nochmal komplett die EM durch. Antenneanstössig. Wir gehen nochmal alles durch. Auch Jogi Löw wird nochmal komplett zurück analysiert. Jogi Löw. Jogi Löw wird nochmal komplett aufgerollt, die gesamte Epoche Jogi. Wer kommt als nächstes? Wer ist der nächste Bundestrainer? Hansi. Hansi Löw? Flick. Ach so. Das war es von meinem Anstoß. Aber wie wird das? Wird das auch gewählt mit weissem Rauch oder so? Gibt es da Prozesse, die Trainer der Bundesligamannschaften wählen das? Oder wie funktioniert das? Ja, es wird in der DFB-Zentrale gewählt. Da kommen alle DFB-Funktionäre zusammen und setzen sich in so Fussballtrikots, also sehr traditionellen Fussballtrikots mit hohen, grossen Stutzen zusammen und setzen sich in einen Kreis und wählen dann. Ja. Und an der Decke ist ein Riesengemälde von dem Golden Goal von Oliver Bierhoff. Ja, genau, das ist ganz schön gemalt oben an der Kapelle. Meinst du, Fussballer können besser kickern als Nicht-Fussballer? Oh, gute Frage. Können Golfer besser Minigolf spielen als ich? So, das ist natürlich die Frage. Übertragen sich diese Skills? Weil ich habe auch gehört, dass viele Fussballer gerne FIFA spielen. Da habe ich mir auch gedacht, also erst mal, wow, die kriegen nicht genug von Fussball, es reicht nicht, den ganzen Tag zu trainieren. Erst mal großen Respekt, ihr übt den richtigen Job aus. Berufswahl, eins mit Sternchen. Ja, wenn du Hobby nebenbei dann irgendwie noch Mario Golf spielen würdest, würde auch mal der Trainer an die Tür klopfen und sagen, Sekunde, Goretzky, haben Sie nicht vielleicht den falschen Berufswahl einschlagen? Goretzky war nicht so falsch, wie du jetzt dachtest. Sind Sie vielleicht nicht falsch hier? Kann ich Ihnen diesen Schläger mal anbieten? Glaubst du, dass Fußballprofis häufig mal so zu einer Berufsinformation gehen und sagen, ich würde mich gerne mal umorientieren? Ich glaube nämlich nicht. Ja,, ich weiß es nicht. Ich glaube, du musst nämlich so Fan sein von dem Sport. Auch zum Beispiel mein Lieblings-Formel-1-Fahrer, Landon Norris, der immer noch, sobald er aus dem Auto steigt, in den Simulator zu Hause steigt und das auf Twitch streamt. Immer so ein Matchbox-Auto in der Tasche hat, unterwegs. Und wenn er nicht gerade bei Twitch ist, ist er auf Formel-1-Strecke, dann ist er bei Twitch und hängt dann da in seinem Simulator rum, der gebaut ist wie ein Formel-1-Sitz und fährt dann da rum oder guckt sich seine Rennen nochmal an und bespricht die da mit dem Publikum, was super spannend ist. Aber das selbst für mich als Formel-1-Fan, zu viel Formel-1-Content von alleine ihm. Das ist schon krass. Ja, der mag das, aber ich glaube, Berufsorientierung ist ein heißes Thema. Ich glaube, es ist auch, du hast einen großen Vertrauensvorsprung, wenn du Berufsorientierungsmentor bist. Wie wird man das? Ich weiß es auch nicht. Und dann kommt jemand rein und sagt, was könnte ich machen? Sie könnten Berufsorientierungsmentor werden, also denselben Job wie ich. Können Sie dir den Job empfehlen? Wie sind Sie zu dem Job gekommen? Wie wurde damals gesagt, ich soll berufs-, als die damals eine Stelle frei geworden ist, bei dem er arbeitsamt. Wie ist der an den Job gekommen? Der wurde gesagt, von dem der Berufsorientierung, wo er hingegangen ist, werden sie berufsorientiert. Und sein Berufsorientierungstippgeber war ein Ex-Fußballer. War dann nicht. Immer im Kreis, aber da kommt dann so ein David Copperfield und sagt, sagen Sie keinem, dass ich hier war, aber diese Zaubereinummer, das zieht sich. Also immer da diese Säge und dann, dass der Eiffelturm verschwindet. Wo ist der hin? Ich habe den im Keller. Und meine ganzen Klone, meine ganzen, die ganze Fackel Klone.
Da muss nur einer mal raus und mich erpressen.
Ich bin ja Drilling, also kann ich dir anvertrauen.
Ich bin ja ein Drittel eines Drillingstriumvirats, eines Trios.
Und ich habe die Freitestatue im Keller, es nimmt zu viel Platz weg, es ist super ätzend.
Ich würde gerne was mit Menschen machen, können Sie da was empfehlen?
Ich bin da ein bisschen gebrandmarkt, weil damals mein Tennistrainer, der hat mir immer gesagt, wenn Leute gescoutet werden, die sehr gut im Tennis sind zum Beispiel und dann irgendwie für den Westdeutschen Tennisverband oder sowas, die DFB des Tennis gescoutet werden und dann für, ja, da wird halt Geld in dich investiert und dann kannst du so eine Karriere starten als professioneller Tennisspieler. Und da gibt es halt so Vorführungssessions und Trainingsessions, Spiele, die sich angeguckt werden von so Scouts und auch immer so einen Testwohl, dass sie ab und zu mal so Bälle aufs Feld werfen und nichts sagen, keine Anweisung geben und so. Und die gucken einfach, wie lange die Spieler brauchen, um mal zu den Bällen zu gehen, sich den Ball zu schnappen, mit dem Ball rumzuspielen, auf dem Schläger rumzutitschen, weil die sagen, das muss so in dir drin sein, dieser Wunsch, Tennisspieler zu sein, dass du es nicht ertragen kannst, wenn deine Bälle auf dem Feld sind und du Schläger in der Hand hast, nichts mit diesen Bällen zu machen. Und fahren die dann auch in so einem schwarzen Van hinter denen her und werfen denen mal so im Supermarkt so einen Tennisball unterm Regal durchrollen. Ja, so The Shining-mäßig, wenn die dann irgendwo, keine Ahnung, abends auf der Tanzfläche steht da hinten einfach so ein Mann mit einem Trenchcoat, der so eine Tasche greift und so einen Ball rausnimmt und so langsam mit offenem Mund und riesengroßen Augen. Und im Glas ist so ein Tennisball. Schwimmt so bedrohlich und dann so, was machst du jetzt? Das ist schon geil. Aber wenn er einfach nimmt und wegwirft, diese Karriere ist nichts für dich. Wenn er einen Aufschlag macht, 180 kmh, schön dem Barkeeper ins Gesicht, gescoutet. Aber passiert ihnen vielleicht auch manchmal, dass sie falsch scouten, also dass sie den besten Tennisspieler der Welt suchen, aber zufällig den besten Golfer finden und also schiebt man die sich dann untereinander zu. Dann aber auch denken, ja gut, wer bin ich jetzt, das zu bewerten. Ja, aber schiebt man die sich dann zu oder versucht man eher andere Sportarten kleinzuhalten? Das ist schon wie Tauschen, das ist ein Tauschspiel. Wie Pokémon-Karten? Ja, wie Pokémon-Karten, ich bin ein bisschen Golfer, ich bin immer Tennis-Profi, also ich sammle eher Käfer-Pokémon, so hab aber jetzt Pikachu-Gold. Aber wie scoutest du Leute, die den Sport noch nicht machen? Wie ich immer fragen, Sätze falsch vollende. Du sagst was und ich habe keine Ahnung, in welche Richtung es geht, bin aber sehr begeistert von dem Gedanken. Wie scoutet man Menschen, die nicht gescoutet werden vorher? Genau, im Grunde eigentlich, du bist der neue Pirlo oder was und bist der Beste und du musst aber gucken. Deine jüngeren Wüste von 80er-Jahr-Referenzen, die auch vor deiner Zeit waren. Du bist so zwischen den Welten gefahren. Du musst aber gucken, das ist die Challenge, du darfst nicht gescoutet werden. Du musst dein ganzes Leben auf deinem Bolzplatz in Palermo spielen und darfst nicht gescoutet werden. Das ist ein Film, der Profi, der keiner werden wollte. Der wollte nur mit seinen Jungs bolzen, ein bisschen so irgendwie vornüber beugen und dann so mit voller Wucht auf den Arsch schießen. Ja, das ist ein Film, das ist ein sehr langweiliger Film. Aber alle wollten, dass er in der Profiliga spielt und er wollte aber nicht. Ich dachte die ganze Zeit, als ich von diesem Trick erfahren habe, shit, vielleicht werde ich jetzt gescoutet, weil ich jetzt von diesem Trick weiß. Ich weiß aber, dass ich das normalerweise, der Drang von mir, so komplett aus eigenem Antrieb jetzt zu diesem Ball zu gehen und in die Hand zu nehmen, rumzuspielen, wäre vielleicht nicht so groß wie bei anderen Spielern, aber ich weiß jetzt von diesem Trick, also würde ich das machen. Vielleicht werde ich Tennisprofi und habe es eigentlich gar nicht verdient. Ich würde dann die ganze Zeit mit dem schlechten Gewissen rumlaufen und denken, ich bin nur hier, weil ich damals diesen Ball in die Hand genommen rumgetitscht habe, obwohl ich das vielleicht gar nicht wollte. Und dann musst du bei der Preisverleihung, wenn du den Pokal in die Höhe streckst, sagen, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp. Nicht so doll applaudieren. Ich will nur kurz was sagen. Ich weiß, beim Tennis schlagen die Wogen extrem hoch, wenn man hier irgendwas gewinnt. Alle Kameras der Welt sind auf mich gerichtet. Alle Eurosport-5-Kameras sind auf mich gerichtet. Ich habe diesen Preis nicht verdient. Und alle drei Zuschauer. Ich habe damals den Ball genommen, obwohl alle, hä, was noch reden? Weil ich habe erfahren, was dies gab. Aber schöne Kameras. Ich will eigentlich Kameramann werden. Richtig tolle Kameras. Weißt du noch, damals, als wir die unwahrscheinlichen Ereignisse gemacht haben, diese WDR-Show, dieses deutsche SNL, was es eigentlich werden wollte. Ich ich habe letztens über Nacht gedacht, wie redet man über Dinge, die man nicht gut fand. Und was da immer so war, wenn Leute über die Sendung gesprochen haben, sagen wir, ja, ich habe die Sendung gesehen und ihr habt echt krasse Kameras. Also richtig, richtig krasse Kameras. Zusammengefasst, man kriegt nie das Lob für das, wovon man es eigentlich will. Weil selbst wenn man was cooles macht oder so, wenn man dann Lob bekommt für etwas, meistens verletzt einen das. Genau, weil du kriegst ja das Lob für was anderes. Also wenn du sagen willst, A ist schlecht, sagst du B war richtig gut. Wenn du im Restaurant bist und sagst, Mensch die Tischdecken sind der Traum. Also fantastische Tische. Und irgendwann kippt es auch. So schön habe ich die. Wenn immer mehr Leute reinkommen und sagen, diese Tischdecken wollen und fragen, woher die sind und so. Ich habe mal ein Restaurant angerufen, weil ich die Wandfarbe wissen wollte. Wo ich mir mal dachte, was denken die jetzt von dem, also sind die nicht sauer? Und irgendwann fangen die Wandfarbe zu verkaufen und die steht mit auf der Karte, weil die merken, vielleicht, da sehen wir es wieder, vielleicht sind wir kein Restaurant, vielleicht wurden wir damals falsch gescoutet. Wir sind ein Interieur-Design-Laden. Und dann verändert sich das so Stück für Stück. Irgendwann ist es 50-50 und dann läuft es über in Wandladen. Nee, ich dachte, es war hier im Kaizen in Köln, in Sushi-Laden. Und das war so eine tolle Wandfarbe und da war man kurz vor meinem Umzug und ich dachte, ich will diese Wandfarbe haben. So eine Mischung. Und das ist jetzt nicht so einfach zu verstehen, weil ich jetzt Farben sage, die erstmal nichts mit mir zu tun haben. Aber in dieser Farbe kam alles zusammen. Und je nachdem, wie dann das Licht auch kam, es war eine Mischung aus Grau. Aber es war nicht grau, es war eher grün. Aber es war nicht grün-grau, es war eher auch blau. Aber nicht unangenehm, sondern es war einfach alles, je nachdem wir das Licht auch so einführen, es war einfach schön. Und dann habe ich danach da angerufen und gefragt, wie diese Wandfarbe heisst. Und wo man auch dann als Restaurant so, fucking hell, haben die mir auch nicht gesagt. Aber hast du dann auch den Namen bekommen? Nein. Sie informieren sich nochmal, sie erfragen das. Sie überdenken nochmal ihr gesamtes Leben. Wir überdenken kurz unser ganzes Leben. Ob sie wirklich ein Restaurant hätten aufmachen können, dann rufen wir jetzt kurz zurück. Viele japanische Flüche im Hintergrund gehört, Schreie, ein scharfes Messer wurde geschwungen und dann wurde aufgelegt. Aber da gibt es auch bestimmte App, wo du so die Wand fotografieren kannst und dann kriegst du die Farbe oder sowas. Dann sagst du dir, was für ein Insekt das wäre, wenn du es ...
Stimmt, die Apps falsch anwenden, die Baum-App auf ein Insekt anwenden.
Ganz kurz, das Mottenproblem spitzt sich langsam zu in meiner Wohnung.
Das ist wirklich um die Idee.
Also um das kurz zusammenzufassen, Stefan Titzer hatte einen epischen Kampf für eine Motte, hat sie ermordet und sie ist durch Staub zerfallen.
Ja.
Und jetzt würde ich als klassischer Fantasy-affiner Mensch denken, aus dem Staub sind dann zwei Motten auferstanden. Genau, Hydra. Das sind eine Hydra. Und du wusstest nicht, wie du damit umgehen sollst. Es werden mehr und größere. Nee, aber es ist jetzt kein Spaß. Ich habe so klein, wie so ein kleiner Vogel, grosse Motten in meiner Minute aufwache, weil diese Motten die ganze Zeit durch meine Wohnung fliegen. Und ich werd die nicht los. Ab und zu seh ich einen rausfliegen in die Weite der Nacht. Und ich denk mir, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao. Könnte auch ein Horrorfilm werden, so ... Moth Attack, hab ich schon gedacht. Ja, so Alfred Hitchcocks Moths. Hat sich nicht so gut durchgesetzt, weil es in sehr vielen Ländern nicht gut auszusprechen war. Ja, ich hätte gerne Kino 3 den Film. Also welchen? Wir haben zwei Kino 3, deswegen frage ich. Moths Moths 1 oder Moths 2? Moths 3D? Oder die Vorsitzende Even More moths. More moths. Ich denke, more moths. Mormons? In Kino zwei? Nee, more moths. Morbus. Ich gehe in Twilight. Morph Attack. Der läuft doch bestimmt irgendeiner. Aber ich bin nachts aufgebracht und da hat man noch so ein Mischung aus Traum und ist man noch in der Realität mit so einer Märchen wie in Zwischenwelt. Und dann dachte ich mir, Moth Attack wäre ein Mega-Band-Name. Moth Attack. Ja, das stimmt schon. Caterpillar Attack, so Tiere, die eigentlich nicht furchteinflössend sind. Moth finde ich mega furchteinflössend. Wirklich? Ja. Aber die haben noch nichts, die haben keinen Stachel, die haben kein Lasso, die haben gar nichts. So, da habe ich gegoogelt, sind grosse Motten gefährlich in meiner Wohnung? Motte, auch Motte. Allein der Name sagt doch schon, nimm dich in acht vor diesen Tieren. Ja, aber das klingt auch wie ein Spitzname für so ein bisschen so ein Hamburger Jung. Motte, aber auch wie so ein bisschen rebellisches Mädchen so. Das ist Motte. Hä, ich bin mit dem System unzufrieden. Das ist Motte. Das klingt auch schon ganz cool eigentlich. Ja, aber das ist Rewonklinge. Aber es ist keine große Gefahr. Der Kapitalismus wird nicht wanken wegen Motte.
Meinst du nicht?
Das passiert nicht. Nein, nein, nein. Motte geht immer nach Peru und dann ist auch das mal gut. Nein, genau, geht nach Peru und benutzt Secondhand, aber ich glaube, der Kapitalismus wird nicht in Angstschweiß ausbrechen. Und genauso solltest du nicht in Angstschweiß ausbrechen, wenn du Motte siehst. Ich habe mal gegoogelt und dann dann habe ich nur die überschrift gesehen und war irritiert warum große motten so gefährlich sind und dann habe ich erst mal angst gehabt irgendwann habe ich dann genug aufmerksamkeit spanner wieder auf war wieder aufgeladen meine meine ladebalken ab und wieder ans licht gegangen wieder ans licht gegangen und habe das dann drauf und dann kam raus weil die nämlich Eier legen in dem Essen, was bei mir
offen rum stünde, gäbe es Essen,
was offen rum stünde, würden sie
darin Eier legen, die bei mir Magenprobleme auslösen.
Und dann schlüpfen die Motten in deinem
Bauch. Oh Gott!
Aber genau, so eine Riesenmotte.
Das ist so Alien-mässig.
Die dann mitisst. So ein Wirt.
Ja.
Das ist wirklich, was macht man denn dagegen? Wo kommt die denn her? Ja, aber vielleicht ist es der neue Abnehm-Trend. Guck mal, das ist doch genial, wenn du Motten-Eier isst und die Motten essen das Essen aus deinem Magen. Das ist doch der perfekte Abnehm-Trend. Wenn die ein Teil deines Essen-Essens. Es gibt doch, glaube ich, es gibt so Diätbandwürmer, glaube ich, die du, ich glaube, die Langen von Haribo, die du dann so schön und musst halt am Stück runterschlucken einmal, da darfst du nicht zerbeissen. Ja, wenn du reinbeisst, hast du ein Riesenproblem. Das sind Riesenprobleme. Weil dann hast du, das sind leere Kalorien hoch tausend. Und die fressen das auf, bevor es verdaut wird und dann ideal. Meine Frage ist, also Step 1, dieser großen Odyssee, die uns jetzt erwarten wird, und über die nächsten zehn Folgen will es sich erstrecken, Frage eins erstmal jetzt und Phase eins dieser ganzen Problematik ist, herausfinden, kommen die aus der Wohnung, schlüpfen die irgendwo in meiner Wohnung, habe ich irgendwo ein Nest, gibt es Mottennester oder kommen die einfach von draußen, weil ich halt immer meine Fernsehspangel weit offen lasse und Licht drin ist? Ja, oder jetzt kommt halt Schritt zwei und du holst dir Spinnen ins Haus oder irgendwas, was diese Motten eliminiert. Und dann musst du halt gucken, dann holst du dir halt gegen die Spinnen wieder einen Leguan. Und am Ende dieser Kette ist eine Freundin wahrscheinlich. Weil, überleg mal, jetzt will ich mir Spinnen für eine Motte, dann müssen die Spinnen gegessen werden von einem anderen Tier. Dann brauche ich ein grösseres Tier, habe ich vielleicht eine Katze oder so. Oder so ein Leguan oder so ein Chameleon. Und dann kriege ich jetzt die ganzen Leguan raus. Und am Ende ist es wahrscheinlich einfach ein Mensch, der mir hilft, das alles rauszunehmen. Genau, und am Ende hast du eine süße Katze und eine tolle Familie. Ja, aber es ist eine komplette Familie. Aber es ist schon wild, wenn du jetzt so einen Bandwurm im Magen lebst, der ist ja immer dunkel. Ist es wirklich dunkel im Körper? Habe ich mir tatsächlich ganz akute Gedanken gemacht. Die Kühlschrankfrage. Die Kühlschrankfrage, weil ein kleines Experiment, das ich gemacht habe. Ich war ja diese Woche im Urlaub und ich hatte viel Zeit, weil ich keinen Internetzugang hatte. Dadurch hast du jeden Tag ungefähr zwölf Stunden Zeit, die nicht gefüllt sind. Und was ich gemacht habe, ist, ich hatte meine Handykamera offen und mir ist aufgefallen, dass wenn du mit deinem Finger auf die Linse drückst, dann wird das Bild rot. Aber wenn du die Linse irgendwie an dein T-Shirt drückst, dann wird es schwarz. Sprich, durch deinen Finger kommt irgendwie Licht durch. Damit es nicht schwarz ist. Dann hatte ich mir eigentlich, vielleicht ist es im Körper nicht stockdunkel. Vielleicht kommt durch die Haut schon ein bisschen Rot, vielleicht ist da wirklich so Rotlicht im Körper drin, wenn durch die Haut ein bisschen was durchgeht. Ja, an manchen Punkten kann ich mir das vorstellen. Und dann ist nichts Problem. Ich habe mir vor einiger Zeit den Zeh gebrochen und ich habe ja lange geglaubt an, was sich nicht umbringt, macht die stärker. Und das war eines der ertäuschendsten Erlebnisse meines Lebens, denn nein, alles, was dich nicht kaputt macht, macht dich zart wie ein Kätzchen und verwundbar für den Rest deines Lebens. Macht dich proportional verwundbarer gegenüber der Verletzung, die du so hast. Du hast jetzt eine Schwachstelle. Du hast jetzt bei Madrid Prime so ein blinkendes Kreuz, wo man genau weiß, da muss ich drauf schießen.
Und bei mir ist es der Zeh.
Und ich habe dann gegoogelt, weil ich war super faul, ich habe mein Zeh gebrochen und der stand so im 90-Grad-Winkel von meinem Fuß ab. Und ich habe aber ernsthaft gegoogelt, muss man damit unbedingt zum Arzt gehen oder kann ich jetzt so weiterleben? Mein Problem war halt, dass ich meine Schuhe nicht mehr anziehen konnte, weil das ging halt nicht. Aber da hieß es auch, jeder Mensch bricht sich im Laufe seines Lebens
mehrmals Zehen,
aber merkt das nicht, weil die wachsen dann einfach
wieder zusammen und das sind ja so ganz dünne Knochen.
Ist nicht so wild. Und jetzt glaube
ich, habe ich mir im Urlaub wieder
ein Zeh gebrochen. Und wenn du dieses Wissen hast,
jeder bricht sich ab und zu Zehen,
ohne es zu merken, und dein
Fuss fühlt sich plötzlich so komisch
an und du denkst, ist das gebrochen oder nicht? Genau wie man isst in seinem Leben sieben Spinnen. Ja, aber das wurde auch schon oft debunkt, glaube ich. Es sind, glaube ich, vier. Also ich glaube, die Zahl geht drastisch wieder nach unten. Das ändert gerade alles. Fünf und drüber und ich ziehe aus. Es kommt darauf an, wie viele Motten du im Haus hast. Oder ist das so weltweit und in Deutschland ist man aber, in Mitteleuropa ist man eigentlich nur eine Spinne. Ja, und es gibt so ein Land, wo das so richtig hochzieht. Und alle so, Entschuldigung, und die so, what? Monte Carlo so, oder irgendwie sowas. So ein kleines Land, das den Weltdurchschnitt. Welches Land hat proportional zu seiner Grösse den grössten Einfluss auf irgendeine Statistik über die Welt? Welches Land ist proportional zur Grösse am besondersten in einer gewissen Kategorie? Ich glaube, Monaco bist du da gar nicht so weit weg. So Reichtum einfach. Reichtum einfach, ja.
Meinst du?
Ja.
Meinst du? Ja. Meinst du? Meinst du? Ja, ich glaube, Monaco ist extrem und die Dichte da an Formel-1-Fahrern, die da leben, ist auch extrem. Also generell, Monaco bist du, glaube ich, sehr, sehr gut dabei. Und wie sehr würden wir Monaco runterziehen, wenn wir da jetzt hinziehen? Dann sagen die bei der Einwanderungsbehörde, ihnen ist schon klar, mit ihrer Staatsbürgerschaft ziehen sie den Gesamtvermögen, Durchschnittsvermögen von Monaco um 20 Prozent runter. Sie machen uns kaputt. Ja, wir kommen nur wegen der Spinnen. Aber dann war es bei mir so weit, dass ich, ich habe dann diese beiden Erlebnisse, einerseits mein Finger lässt rotes Licht durch, andererseits mein Fuß tut weh, haben dazu geführt, dass ich mir dachte, kann man irgendwie Röntgen improvisieren? Kann ich meinen Fuß durchleuchten? Schluck doch mal eine GoPro. Ja. Und dann guck mal einfach, was du siehst. Ja, es gibt ja so Chirurgen. Ja gut, aber der Magen. Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee Ernst, warum nicht? Was soll denn passieren? Das Problem ist, wenn du sie schluckst, ist sie ja im Magen und dann ist sie ja sozusagen doppelt, dann ist sie im Schlafsack im Zelt.
Ja gut, die Frage kam ja daher, was sieht ein Bandwurm in deinem Magen? Und ich glaube, der sieht nicht so viel, weil da ist so viel los. Da ist zu viel Darm, Dickdarmwand im Weg, glaube ich. Ja, das stimmt schon. Aber ich glaube, das ist so wie im Meer, so je tiefer du tauchst, desto weniger Licht wird, aber es wird nie null. So, ich glaube, so ganz tief unten hast du trotzdem noch so ein bisschen Licht. Ich hätte immer Bock auf so eine Rick-and-Morty-artige Serie aus dem Körper. So ein bisschen wie es war immer das Leben, aber jetzt nicht mit diesem süssen Lernanspruch, schon auch mit Lernanspruch, aber halt nur mit so weissen Blutkörperchen, Nervenzellen, Bakterien reden miteinander, Viren reden miteinander.
Also so Rick-and-Motty-artiger Humor. Die Frage ist, wer ist die Hauptfigur? Milz, oder? Ich würde eher Dinge geben, die auch mobil sind, Dinge, die umlaufen können. So eine Polle, die eingeatmet wurde. Oh ja. Ja gut, aber das muss der Antagonist sein. Die Polle muss der Antagonist sein. Du meinst, das ist so ein Gaststar, ich sprache von John Oll. Ja, ich glaube, das ist die Sommerfolge, wo alle Badehosen anhaben und irgendwie am Strand sind, da kommt dann die Pollenfolge oder sowas. Okay, dann brauchen wir jetzt aber einen Charakter, der die ganze Zeit im Körper ist, immer da ist. Weil wie so ein weisses Blutkörperchen? Ich glaube, rot und weisses Blutkörperchen sind schon ein gutes Duo. So ein bisschen Salt-and-Pepa-mässig, so ein bisschen, die streiten sich dann so ein bisschen, wer ist wichtiger für den Körper und so weiter. Werden auch manchmal angegriffen. Und müssen überall hin. Müssen überall hin, können auch überall hin. Und können über die Blutautobahn eigentlich überall hin. Und dann hast du halt so die Grippefolge, wo irgendwas kommt. Und auch immer die Koffeinfreunde. Hallo, hallo, hey, hey, hey, hey, ganz kurz, ganz kurz, eine Sache. Lass mich andocken, lass mich andocken, bitte, bitte, bitte, lass mich andocken, lass mich andocken. Woran? Und dann hast du, das war der Call-Up, oder? Dann hast du es ab und zu. Dann kommt das siebenminütige Intro. Ja, genau. Mit nur Körpergeräuschen, die aber symphonisch kombiniert wurden. Oh, ich hasse Herzschlag. Ich hasse das Geräusch von Herzschlag. Ich weiss nicht, was das ist, aber immer wenn in irgendeiner dummen Schlag, in Rabshow oder so, Spannung und dann kommt immer dieser Herzschlag und ich muss da echt teilweise wegschalten. Ich kann das nicht, ich mag das nicht, dieses Wissen, dass da so eine zunge Pumpe rumpumpt, die jede Sekunde aufhören könnte. Genau, exakt, das ist bei mir auch nämlich so. Warum hört die nicht auf? Warum hört es nicht auf? Manchmal hört es auf und das ist nicht gut. Weil ich meine zum Beispiel mein Arm schläft manchmal ein, so der ist halt einfach kurz raus. Ja, dann hat es halt nicht aufgehört, aber es hat leise. Dein Herz ist dann eher so. Oh fuck, oh fuck, so. Ja, manchmal verkehrt sich zu atmen im Schlafen und denkt man auch so, ja, warum soll ich nicht aufhören? Ja, warum schläft nicht das Herz, weil das Herz muss ja nur eine halbe Minute eingeschlafen sein und das aus. Während der Arm, wochenlang ist der, weil du brauchst ja manche Körperteile einfach eine Zeit lang nicht. Ja. Und warum ist, es gibt da wahrscheinlich gute Antworten, aber die finde ich wahrscheinlich auch eklig. Ja, wir wollen keine guten Antworten. Nee, ich will das nicht. Schreibt, also falls ihr Mediziner seid, schreibt einfach, passt schon, das geht so schnell nicht aus. Nö, das kriegt ihr schon hin. Da gibt's irgendeine, die Milz passt auf oder oder irgendwie so die Lunge übernimmt dann kurz, falls das Herz ausschaltet. Gebt uns die beruhigende Kinderantwort der wissenschaftlichen Antwort. Genau, gebt euch die Antwort, die ihr eurem Kind geben würdet, kurz bevor es einschläft, wenn es kurz vorm Einschlafen Angst hat, dass das Herz aufhört zu schlagen. Ich habe nur gerade gedacht, wenn du sagst, unser Leben lang essen wir sieben Spinnen, unser Leben lang brechen wir uns sieben bei ich dachte mir, da gibt es eine Korrelation, weil ich dachte mir, weil ich habe heute so ein Video gesehen über eins der Millennium- Probleme, ja, liebe Hörer, es kommt zurück, wir sind wieder da, löst die halt mal, dann müssen wir nicht ständig über die reden, so, ja, und zwar ist der ein Millennium-Problem, dass man herausfinden will, ob es ein bestimmtes Gesetz gibt, eine Formel, nach der man berechnen kann, wann Primzahlen auftauchen. Und da hat, was ich fantastisch finde, gab es halt damals mal Euler, der irgendwann gesagt hat, wir gucken mal quasi alle Zahlen unten auf der x-Achse, stell dich mal kurz alle Zahlen vor, die es gibt, unendlich so. Und ja, das hat bis drei Millionen gemacht. Und die y-Achse ist Anzahl Primzahlen. So, und dann immer, wenn es eine Primzahl gibt, müsst ihr euch vorstellen, machst du ein Kreuz dahin, wie viel die Primzahl das ist. Und dann hast du so eine aufsteigende Kurve. Wie so eine Treppe, die immer flacher wird. Genau, eine Treppe, nee, die wird nicht flacher, im Gegenteil, die ist super linear. Ein bisschen flacher war sie, glaube ich, schon. Aber die ist super, schöne Kurve und so. Und irgendwann hat Riemann oder noch jemand davor plötzlich gesagt, ach krass, das ist ja genau wie und jetzt habe ich keine Ahnung, wie die Seta-Formel. Das darf jetzt nicht fehlen. Doch, völlig okay, dass es fehlt. Glaub mir, wenn du das Video gesehen hast, ist es völlig egal, dass es fehlt, weil da an diesem Punkt werden wir niemals landen.
Okay. Das sind die Seta-Formel oder sowas und dann hast du da aber irgendwie eine komplexe Zahl vorne eingefügt in diese Gleichung und nicht einfach nur eine Eins oder eine Zwei, sondern du hast halt das X quasi ersetzt durch eine komplexe Formel und diese, wenn du diese Seta-Formel etwas komplexem fühlst, ergibt das plötzlich eins zu eins diese Kurve. Und ich dachte mir, genial. Und es ist ja nicht nur Mathematik. Wir müssen dann einfach mal, weil wir sind ja hier im Podcast-UFO, wir sind ja gesellschaftliche Observer. Wir gucken, was läuft falsch in der Welt, wie sieht unser Alltag aus. Wir sind ja Beobachter des Alltags hier. So, und deswegen möchte ich gerne mal, dass wir, wo sind Zusammenhänge? Koalitions entdecken, ja. Weil es gibt ja nicht nur Koalitions in Mathematik, es gibt ja auch genauso im echten Leben. Aber ich finde das nicht schlecht, einfach mal über diesen Pi-Grafen, über diese ähm, ähm, seht ihr da? Diesen Grafen, nee, Primzahlen-Grafen, einfach mal alle anderen Grafen drüberlegen. Einfach mal Verkaufszahlen von Zott Monte im Jahre 2018. Einfach mal drüberlegen und gucken, eine wird doch genau treffen, oder? Eine muss doch genau exakt diese Formel sein. Und dann mal schauen, die Länge von den Haribo-Würmlies im Laufe der Zeit. Und dann gucken, ist das wirklich Zufall? Ich glaube, da ist was dran. Ja, und die Riemann-Hypothese ist ja jetzt, und da kommen wir jetzt ins Spiel, weil die gilt es nämlich zu beweisen. Die wollten wir eigentlich letztes Jahr gelöst haben, aber haben es leider nicht geschafft. War das die, die wir beweisen sollten? Das klangen die, die am kompliziertesten waren. Weil jetzt hat der irgendwie so eine Formel aufgestellt, die ab und zu null ist. So, und die ist immer null an einem gewissen Punkt. Und dann gibt es halt so ein paar Zahlen, da ist klar, dass es null ist, aber es gibt halt non-trivial Zahlen, wo es null ist. Und das sind alles Primzahlen. Und er hat es also quasi so ein bisschen geschafft, herauszurechnen. Man kann es aber nicht beweisen, dass das immer Primzahlen sind. Man hat zwar jetzt den Computer dann ewig lange rechnen lassen, und ja, bei jeder Primzahl ist es gleich null an der Stelle, aber niemand weiß genau warum. Und das kann man nicht beweisen. Und nicht mal ein Computer kann es beweisen. Wenn ihr Mathematiker, Mathematikerin seid, schreibt uns eine Nachricht und sagt, das passt schon alles, ist okay, ihr könnt ins Bett gehen, seid beruhigt, das wird schon gehen. Es ist zwar nicht bewiesen, aber das stimmt schon. Aber wie kann man das beweisen, ist auch meine Frage. Also kann man einfach sagen, mein Name ist Stefan Michael Tietze, ich habe es dreimal gegengerechnet, auch bei mir kommt immer Null raus bei Primzahlen. Was wollt ihr mehr? Nee, im Ernst, was wollt ihr mehr? Unterschrieben. PS, ich will die eine Million wieder auf dieses Konto. Die eine Million bitte es bitte schicken an Sparkasse Köln-Bonn. Hier ist meine Konto-Nummer. IBAN. Das sollte generell PS sein eigentlich. Egal was ihr schreibt, immer PS meine IBAN und dann schreibt ihr die einfach hin. Irgendjemand wird überweisen. Das ist genau wie wenn du im Internet oder so in einem offiziellen Forum deine IBAN postet, irgendjemand wird dir fünf Cent überweisen. Das ist eine sehr gute Idee, seine Iban öffentlich rumzuposten. Warum nicht eigentlich? Ich glaube, man kann da nichts einfach ab... Weil früher, es gab doch, ich bin doch aufgewachsen im Internet mit dem Gedanken, gib nirgendwo deine Kreditkartennummer an, gib nirgendwo deine Kreditkartennummer an. Ich glaube, das ist kein schlechter... Und ich habe bis heute nicht verstanden, genau warum. Damit Leute das nicht dann irgendwo selber eintragen, wenn sie was bestellen, und tragen sie deine Kreditkartennummer ein. Die wollen ja mehr als meine Kreditkartennummer. Ja, da kann man ja was machen. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich glaube, ohne Scheiß-These, das ist schon alles relativ sicher. Und damit bin ich gut gefahren bislang. Bei mir wurde tatsächlich mal meine Handynummer geleakt in einem Stream. Gut, die war auch sehr leicht zu erraten. Die ist tatsächlich sehr leicht zu erraten. Wenn man sich ein bisschen mit mir beschäftigt, kommt man auch wieder auf. Wenn man sich ein bisschen mit dir und mit Zahlen beschäftigt, kommt man schon mal auf. Sehr lauf. Meine Handynummer wurde geleakt und ich dachte mir, fuck, Alter, shit, jetzt rufen mich Leute an und die tragen die überall ein und Scams und es ist gar nichts passiert. Überhaupt gar nichts. Bömermann hat ja mal mein Passwort für alles verraten. Wie war das nochmal? Möchte ich nicht verraten, weil es immer noch mein Passwort ist. Nein, das stimmt nicht ganz. Aber es sind doch bei manchen Services noch mein Passwort. Er hat es damals in dem Podcast bei Fest und Flauschig verraten. Und ohne Scheiß hat sich mein Leben nicht verändert. Ich sagte kurz, okay, mein Leben ändert sich. Weil jetzt alles wird geleakt.
Überall werden es Leute bei Amazon, die sich einloggen
und Dinge kaufen und bei Apple.
Nichts passiert.
Es funktioniert schon. Beruhigt euch alle mal.
Ja, heute ist die grosse beruhige Folge.
Beruhigt euch mal, legt euch nochmal hin.
Dinge funktionieren. Alles ist gut.
Sternchen. Alles ist in Ordnung.
Bis auf die Dinge, die es nicht sind.
Aber die werden gut. Ich glaube, es sollte auch manche Dienste geben, wo man kein Passwort brauchen sollte. So in diesem Fall ist es ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr brauchen sollte. So irgendwie so Letterbox, wo du die Filme archivierst, die du angeschaut hast. Was gebe ich da als Passwort ein? Film, Film, Film, eins, zwei, drei. Ist mir doch egal. Wenn mir Leute da Filme eintragen können, die ich nicht gesehen habe, hu. Man sollte es eigentlich so ein Kreuzchen geben, ich verzichte auf Passwort und bin mir mit den Konsequenzen bewusst, ciao. Diese Option soll das geben. Mir ist das zu egal, vor allem, weil wenn diese Angebote dann auch noch haben, sie brauchen eine Zahl und mindestens zwei Großbestaben und Sonderzeichen nicht mehr. Wisst ihr, wer ihr seid? Ihr seid ein öffentlicher Sandkasten im Park. Und dafür soll ich jetzt ein super krasses Passwort angeben, oder was?
Bitte ein Sonderzeichen und mindestens ein Ausrufezeichen.
Und es muss das Wort Igel beinhalten.
Darf kein deutsches Wort beinhalten.
Dann sag mir das Passwort, was du willst.
Dann gib mir das, was alle haben.
Gib mir das, was die meisten anderen haben.
Ich war gestern im Apple Store in einer Genius Bar, wo man ist, wenn man was kaputt hat. Meine Airpods sind kaputt gegangen. Eigentlich idiotbar. So, eigentlich ist die idiotbar. Vollidiot. Idiotstreffen auf Geniuses. Und dann wird man da platziert wie so ein Arztwartebereich, wird man da hingesetzt und dann kommt irgendwann so einer der Geniuses vorbei und duzt dich und redet mit dir nett. Und repariert nebenbei deine ganzen Probleme. Das war eigentlich ganz cool. Und neben mir saß ein Mann und der kam nicht mehr klar mit seinem Laptop, ging auch nicht irgendwie an und so, dann haben sie aber repariert und dann musste er ein Passwort festlegen. Jetzt müssen Sie das Passwort. Und dann hat er ganz lange gesagt, nee, ich weiß nicht, mir fällt nichts ein, mir fällt nichts ein, gar nichts. Und dann meinte der Genius dann, ich kann Ihnen auch ein Passwort nehmen, gegeben, ich schreibe mir das auf und Sie nehmen das. Und er hat gesagt, ja, vielen Dank, vielen Dank. Und ich dachte mir, ja, eigentlich ja. Diesen Genius bräuchte man auch im Leben. Ich hätte gerne einen Genius, der immer an meiner Seite ist, und so sagt, nee, mach da einfach das gleiche Passwort, was er bei Amazon auch schon hat. Vielleicht ist das das neue Geschäftsmodell von Apple, falls man den Computer nicht mehr läuft, einfach so, rent a genius, weil die haben ja genug Genies, die haben ja genug Geniuses rumstehen, ganz im Keller voll, die können ihn einfach vermieten und da richtig viel Geld verdienen. Aber ich finde diese Vorstellung sehr gut von diesem Wartezimmer für die Genius Bar, wo alle rumsitzen und der eine hat irgendwie einfach so einen Pfeil durch seinen Laptop geschossen und sitzt so ungeduldig da. Der andere hat einfach so einen Monitor in zwei Hälften gebrochen und sitzt unglücklich da. Einfach jeder hat ein Problem. Jeder hat ein Problem. Ich war mit meinen Kopfhörern da traurig, saß da rum und dann kam er und seine erste Amtshandlung war, einfach einen Laptop zu haben, wo er ein weirdes Gerät in den USB-Slot reinsteckt. Von seinem oder von deinem? Nee, er hat einen eigenen MacBook gehabt. So, hat er dann so ein weirdes Gerät für sein USB-Ding, hat das da reingesteckt und hat dann meine AirPods an dieses weirde Gerät angeschlossen. Und das weirde Gerät hat nach fünf Minuten gesagt, was das Problem ist. Meine Frage ist, warum gibt es dieses Gerät nicht zu kaufen?
Das ist der eigentliche Genie, das ist das Genius.
Und dann dachte ich mir, macht doch mal das Red Bull-Prinzip, Apple.
Ihr habt ja so viel Geld, es kommt ja nicht mehr aufs Hauptprodukt an.
Ihr könnt ja, macht mal Nebenprodukte, die noch krasser sind.
Weißt du, die können ja auch das verkaufen. Glaubst du nicht, die würden mehr Geld bekommen, diesen Problemscanner zu verkaufen? Weil die haben ja jetzt genug Geld mit Technikkram und so. Jetzt ist das nächste Step, wie die Probleme, um das andere zu lösen, verkaufen die jetzt. Auch ein geiles Produkt. Oder glaubst du, die würden dadurch Geld verlieren? Wahrscheinlich, das kann schon sein. Oder das ist ultraschwer zu bedienen, dieses Gerät. Oder niemand weiss genau, was da drin ist. Das ist so alte Alien-Technologie, die niemand rekonstruieren kann. Und man einfach sagt, lass uns die hier nutzen. Die können wir gar nicht nachbauen. Aus den UFO-Files ist auch gar nichts geworden, ne? Die rauskamen? Nee, ich dachte, wir können da ein großes Special zu machen, UFO-Files, aber das ist alles so albern. Warum sind das nicht coolere Aliens, die fliegen da hin und her und dann ... Weißt du, wenn du denen Aufwand machst, Millionen Lichtjahre durchs Universum zu ballern, das muss ja auch für die Aliens ein Riesenaufwand sein, und dann einmal über dem Meer links, rechts und haust wieder ab oder was? Können die nicht mal landen oder tanken oder sowas? Ja, jetzt müssen wir Hallo sagen. Ja, einfach mal Hi. Posted reicht. Ich meine, ich weiß nicht, ob die diese Post bekommen haben von der Erde. Es gibt ja diese Metallplatte, wo irgendwie die Black Eyed Peas drauf graviert wurden oder so als Stellvertreter der Erde. Vielleicht können die sowas auch dalassen. Wie geil wäre das denn, wenn wir sowas von den Aliens bekommen mit furchtbarer grässlicher Musik und halt auch Crazy Frog ist auch drauf. Und das ist so das Einzige, was uns verbindet, die Erden, Zivilisation und die Aliens, dass wir sind beide gleichzeitig auf Crazy Frog gekommen. Weil das dachte ich mir nämlich jetzt auch, als ich dann dieses Video heute gesehen habe, wo ich mit der Seta-Funktion, dachte ich mir so, ja, aber es ist ja auch eh alles menschengemacht, dass ja nichts allgemeingültiges ist wir können das jetzt nicht mehr mit der Lichtgeschwindigkeit, mit der Naturkonstante verbinden, weil es ist ja alles nur menschengemacht. Zahlen sind ja menschengemacht. Und dann dachte ich mir, nee, dieser Zahlenreihe ist ja egal, dass wir bis zehn rechnen und dann sagen wir elf, zwölf und dann zwanzig, dass wir halt ein Mathematiksystem haben, was in Zehnerschritten vor allem angesehen wird. Ich habe es ein bisschen verwechselt mit Buchstaben. Die sind Menschen gemacht, aber Zahlen ja nicht. Zahlen, etwas, was einzeln ist, hat er nun das Wort Eins. Aber das mal Zehn ist ja immer Zehn. Auch in Alienschrift, wir müssen die ja so rechnen. Im Grunde ja, das stimmt schon. Vielleicht haben die eine Antwort, vielleicht kommen die einfach, vielleicht warten die noch auf genug Millennium-Probleme und kommen dann einfach mal vorbei und lösen einfach mal alle Millennium-Probleme, holen sich die zehn Millionen Dollar und hauen wieder ab. Ich glaube, es gibt bestimmt da so eine Alienbehörde. Aber es ist doch egal, oder? Warte mal, eins, zwei, drei, es ist doch völlig egal, ob wir jetzt bei zehn ... Wir haben ja ein System, was auf zehner Schritten beruht. Stefan ist kurz vorm Lösen eines Millenienproblemen. Bleibt noch mal fünf Minuten dran. Nee, ich bin kurz vorm Lösen von Problemen, von denen ihr gar nicht wusstet, dass wir sie haben. Ey, du stellst ein neues Problem auf und löst alle. Ich glaube, hier passiert gleich was richtig. Da liegt wirklich was in der Luft dran. Aber jetzt denk mal mit nach. Jetzt ist es gerade einfach für dich, dass deine Kom Komfortzone das jetzt Gags machen. Setz mal kurz den Konzentrationshut auf. Wir setzen uns jetzt mal beide den Konzentrationshut auf. Weil ist es nicht egal, das ist meine Frage, Millennienproblem. Ich gebe dir Fünfer, wenn du es löst. Kriegt man das nicht, ist es egal, dass es in Zehner-Schritten angedacht ist? Absolut, ich glaube schon. Absolut egal, ne? Ja. Weil die, ich glaube, Römer oder Griechen haben in Sechser-Schritten gedacht, eher. Aber das ist ja auch egal. Die hätten doch auch V und X und so, das ist doch auch eher Zehner-System, oder? X und dann noch ein Eins. Aber die hatten nur keine Null. Ich weiß, dass die keine Null hatten. Ja, aber dann geht das nicht. Dann funktioniert alles nicht. Warum? Meine Vorstellung ist ja, dass irgendwann Aliens kommen mit so einer Schallplatte. Die haben elf Finger. Und dann haben die auch so einen Graphen gemalt und dann so Gleichlösung für alle Probleme. Und das ist die Weltformel. Dann geben die uns den und dann sagt so ein Euler-artiger Mensch, ach das ist doch Dingsfunktion. Aber dafür müssen wir das gleiche Mathematiksystem haben, oder? Ich glaube, diese hohe Mathematik bewegt sich eh in Sphären, die mit der Realität nichts zu tun haben. Ob du zehn Fleischfinger an dir hast oder nicht, ist völlig egal. Ich glaube, die sind eh in so ganz abstrakten Welten. Ich habe neulich diese Stephen Hawking Schwarze Loch Dokumentation geschaut. Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie die heißt. Reiche ich nach. Bei Netflix gibt es eine, die rausgekommen ist. Über vier Forschungsgruppen und die haben halt das erste Foto eines Schwarzen Lochs gemacht. Ja, dieser Orange Donut. Super grosser Aufwand gewesen und haben mit ganz vielen Teleskomen auf der Welt zusammengearbeitet, hat auf einen Punkt fotografiert und dann mussten die halt, weil das Problem ist ja, wir sind ja primed, wir Menschen sind ja super biased gegenüber Schwarzen Löchern, weil zum einen heisst das Black Hole so, dann haben wir alle Interstellar gesehen, wir haben alle eine Vorstellung, wie schwarze Löcher aussehen.
Das heisst, die haben dann vier Teams gemacht, die alle versucht haben, aus den Bildern, aus dem Bildmaterial herauszurechnen, wie dieses schwarze Loch, weil du musstest halt, du hast sehr viele Bilder gemacht mit Teleskopen und du musstest halt eine Formel bauen, um halt daraus ein Bild zu rechnen im JPEG-Format. Weißt du, du musstest halt irgendwie, das ist ein Rechentakt. JPEG oder PNG, man muss sich halt in den Termin treffen irgendwann. Und da haben die halt sich überlegt, wie kriegen wir das hin, dass da jetzt keine menschlichen Fehler passieren und wir das Bild kreieren, was wir wollen, wie es aussieht.
Und haben dann vier Teams gebaut, die alle unabhängig aneinander versuchen, diese ganzen Files, diese ganzen Zahlen in Bilder zu bekommen. Und am Ende hatten alle ungefähr das gleiche Bild, der orange Donut. Also entweder hatten die alle Hunger und einfach richtig Bock auf so einen Aprikosendonut oder es sieht wirklich so aus. Ja, es sieht wirklich so aus, glaube ich. Und in dieser Dokumentation, das ist fantastisch, gibt es ein Forscherteam, die an der Hawking-Hypothese arbeiten. Und Hawkins Hypothese war, es ist ja die Hawking-Strahlung entdeckt, dass es nicht nur alles ins schwarze Loch reinzieht, sondern das schwarze Loch auch was ausgibt, die Hawking-Strahlung. Und dann war die These, dass rauskommt, was reingekommen ist. Dass das schwarze Loch in etwa das wieder als Strahlung abgibt und man quasi an der Oberfläche ablesen kann, was mal reingeflutscht ist in das schwarze Loch anhand der Strahlung. Und dann gab es ein Team, und mittlerweile haben die das auch veröffentlicht, dieses Paper, aus drei Leuten, zwei superalte Männer und so eine junge Mathematikerin, so so eine Doktorstochter von einem von denen. Und es war unfassbar, die haben einfach eine Formel aufgestellt mit Zahlen, die ich kannte. Die drei war dabei, die neun. Die zwölf war dabei. Die zwölf war dabei. Ich wusste, dass es die Zwölf war es schafft, eine der besten Zahlen, die es gibt. Die haben eine Formel aufgestellt und am Ende musste aus irgendeinem Grund, den ich nicht verstanden habe, zwölf J rauskommen, ich glaube Joule oder sowas. Und
alles, was da vorgebt, musste auch zwölf
Joule ergeben, so. Damit die
herausfinden, dass das, was Reikob rauskommt.
Und dann haben die eine riesige Formel
aufgestellt, so über 173
verschiedene Seiten,
aber halt in Programmen, die man so gefühlt
kennt, so Word, haben die
einfach so Zahlen reingeschickt. Und am Ende musste zwölf 12 Jul rauskommen oder so. Und ich fand das so beeindruckend. Und dann haben sie auf Enter gedrückt und kam dann auch 12 Jul raus. Es kam am Ende 12 Jul raus oder J. Und das Irre, ich fand das so irre, dass die mit diesem theoretischen Konstrukt, was das Loch, einfach mit handfesten Zahlen gearbeitet haben.
Wie ist das möglich? Und da dachte ich mir, ich dachte, ich könnte es verstehen.
Ich lese noch drei Stephen Hawking-Bücher und dann habe ich schon verstanden.
Aber da dachte ich mir, das ist so weit weg, das ist far away.
Nee, absolut.
Wie leere Gehirne funktionieren.
Ich finde solche Dokumentationen auch immer spannend, in der Hinsicht, verstehe ich es oder nicht?
Kann ich das verstehen oder nicht? Bleibt was hängen oder nicht? Meistens habe ich, während ich es schaue, das Gefühl, es verstanden zu haben, danach aber nicht mehr. Danach überhaupt nicht mehr, es bleibt nichts hängen.
Ja, ich denke mir auch so von, wir haben durch das Internet so kondensiertes Wissen, wir haben so viele Reddit-Seiten, das beste Bild der Welt, die interessanteste Geschichte der Welt. Und was ist hängen geblieben nach zehn Jahren? Nachdem wir zehn Jahre lang das kondensierte Menschheitswissen aufgesaugt haben, aufbereitet von intelligenten Content-Creatoren, Reddit-Autoren, Kurzgeschichten. Gangnam Style. Gangnam Style und Crazy Frog, das ist hängen geblieben. Und alles andere, ah, cool, interessant und weg. Ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, Crazy Frog hat mehr Schaden angerichtet, als wir noch, als wir gerade denken, dass es getan hat. Ja? Meinst du, rückblickend wird das die gesamte Kultur überdecken, überstrahlen? Was das an Ohrwürmern ausgelöst hat in Leuten, die eigentlich was Besseres in der Zeit, wo sie diesen Ohrwurm hätten, hätten machen können? Ja. Ich glaube, Crazy Frog wird rückblickend als ein zum Untergang der Menschheit einteil. Cringe-worthy Ereignis. Da sind wir nicht stolz drauf. Ja, und Archäologen halten das für das grösste kulturelle Meisterwerk unserer Epoche und niemand kann mehr sagen, nee, nee, wir sind auch was anderes. Nee, wir sind auch Lady Gaga, die ist auch cool. Ja. Ja, ist schwierig. Vielleicht sollte man so Post-it-Notes hinterlassen, so, wenn die Leute von Pompeji... Du mit deinen Post-its heute? Ja, keine Ahnung. Ich glaube, ich hole mir einen Stapel. Nee, mach mal. Ich glaube, ich hole mir einen Stapel und mache so Einkaufen gehen, überall an die Decke. Mein Plan war auch schon, Post-its zu machen an allen Orten, wo ich Motten gefunden habe zum ersten Mal. Aha, und dann holst du dir so einen roten Faden und verbindest die Orte miteinander. Ja, und so langsam quasi das Epizentrum des Mottenaufkommens. Und dann finde ich so einen kleinen Zugang in die Anderswelt, glaube ich. In die Mottenwelt. Und in der Mottenwelt fliegen dann so kleine Stephans durch die Gegend. Holst du mich aus dem Upside-Down, wenn ich da reingehe? Hm, ne? Also ich würde dich, glaube ich, vermissen. Nach ein paar Wochen würde ich schon merken, dass du nicht mehr da bist. Und dann würde ich vielleicht mal in deiner Wohnung gucken und dann ist so ein kleines glitzerndes Loch bei dir in der Wand. Und dann würdest du sagen, ach nee, nicht schon wieder diese Anderswelt. Nicht schon wieder diese fucking Anders-Mottenwelt. Und dann würde ich da wirklich aber auch so eine Haribo-Schlange da reinlassen und gucken, ob du greifst auf der anderen Seite. Weil ich selber würde keinen einzigen Fussbreit in die Anderswelt stellen. Auf gar keinen Fall. Das ist eines der Prinzipien, die ich mir gesetzt habe, an denen ich festhalte. Würdest du denn so eine Stranger Things-artige Gruppe versammeln, die mich da rausholen wenigstens? Ich will einen Jäger, einen Magier, einen Schurken und einen Priester, die würde ich mir zusammen holen, die da reinschicken, den Jock, den Jock, den Nerd, irgendwie die Lester-Schwester, die Cheerleaderin und die haben alle verschiedene Skills, die würde ich da reinschicken, ich selber, aber nur mit der Haribo-Gummischlange im Hintergrund. Und am Ende finden sie nicht mich, aber zu sich selbst. Diese sehr heterogene Gruppe. Genau, dass sie da irgendwie was Besonderes ist, aber sie gemeinsam stärker sind als davor und sie vielleicht auch ihre Stereotypen überkommen können und die Vorurteile aus dem Weg bereiten. Während ich von grobem, lebensgrossem Motten aufgefressen werde. Stefan haben wir nicht gefunden.
Aber ist okay, ist okay, ist doch gut für euch, das ist ein schönes Abenteuer für euch.
Doch, finde ich gut.
Übrigens vielen Dank an die Community, die tatsächlich ein Stalaktitze gemalt haben.
Wirklich, ich habe keinen gesehen.
Es gab einen einzigen bei Twitter.
Nice.
Aber wo hast du ihn gesehen? Ohne Caption leider.
Ja, wo hast du ihn gesehen? Ja, das ist halt das Problem, wenn es halt nur einer mal ist, es geht halt unter. Aber es ist halt dargeblieben. Aber in welchem Medium? Twitter. Twitter? Ja, geil. Nicht schlecht. Ein Bild von mir, mein Kopf auf einem Stalaktit, Stalaktitze. Und was hat es in dir hervorgerufen? Es fehlte die Überschrift Stalaktit. Ach so, einfach nur... Es war einfach nur mein Bild, aber sehr gut auf Schalatizen gemalt. Das heißt, die Mindestanforderung wurde noch nicht erfüllt. Es gab nicht die Caption. Aber besser, als dass es zwei gemacht haben, finde ich. Das ist ja wie dieses Gedankenexperiment. Du du hast 100 Leute und wenn nur einer den Knopf drückt, dann kriegt der 1000 Euro, aber wenn mehr als einer den Knopf drückt, kriegt niemand was. Kriegt man es hin, dass es wirklich nur einer macht, ohne sich abzusprechen oder dass niemand betrügt oder so? Wie bei The Dark Knight fand ich eine tolle Szene mit den beiden Schiffen. Und wenn die auf den Knopf drücken, fliegt das andere Schiff in die Luft, aber sie selber überleben.
Und am Ende hat Gotham dem Joker bewiesen, dass es besser ist als gedacht.
Ja.
Aber Batman auch.
Nein, Batman hat in diesem Film keine Charakterentwicklung. Aber der hat die doch gerettet.
Weil das ist doch so, wenn die eine gewisse Zeit erreicht, fliegen beide in die Luft.
Fliegt beide in die Luft. Und weil er die davor gerettet hat weil das ist doch so, wenn er eine gewisse Zeit erreicht, fliegen beide in die Luft. Fliegt beide in die Luft.
Und weil er die davor gerettet hat, ist es nicht eingetreten.
Du versuchst jetzt Gotham zum Helden machen, aber der Film heisst nicht The Dark Gotham, sondern Batman, The Batman Movie with Batman. Ich sag nur, bei manchen Filmen muss der Protagonist nicht unbedingt die Lehre mit in sich tragen, sondern der Film an sich hat die Veränderung durchgemacht, die Stadt, die Umwelt. Ich hätte Havident nicht gebraucht in Dark Knight. Ich habe das noch mal gesehen und dachte mir, ach, das hier kommt ja auch noch alles. Ja, das ist alles noch drin. Ach, das ist ja auch Two-Face. Ja, das ist so auch wie, es gibt ja so ein paar Filme, wo man immer so zwischen Schauplätze und her schaltet, Episode 1 oder so, wo du immer denkst, oh Gott, diese Anakin im Raumschiff Nummer, die brauche ich jetzt nicht. Schalt wieder zu dem guten Zeug oder auch bei Herr der Ringe, wo wirklich der Power-Move war. Wir schneiden hin und her zwischen Helmsklamm, der fucking krassesten, spannendsten Schlacht, die es überhaupt gibt, die jemals auf Leinwand gebannt wurde, und Baumbart. das Publikum muss jetzt einfach mal ertragen, dass wir zwischen Baumgart und Hems-Klamm hin und her schneiden. Ich dachte zu jedem Zeitpunkt, wenn auf Hems-Klamm was passiert, werden wir schon wieder hinschalten. Peter Jackson wird ja nicht wegschneiden, wenn gerade irgendwas Tolles kommt. Der Film hat mir die ganze Zeit coole Stories gezeigt, deswegen dachte ich schon, an diesem Punkt werden die es jetzt nicht verkacken. Wenn da was passiert, ich werde es schon mitbekommen. Wie sind zwischen zwei Fußballspielen, wo man weiß, wenn man wegschaltet, ich verpasse nichts. Gemein, wenn du schaltest zurück und Legolas ist tot, man denkt so, warum sollen wir das nicht gesehen haben? Auch ein guter Film eigentlich, ja, schnellst zurück und nein, nee, und dann hast du Legolas im Arm und so, what? Und alle so, hä, warum ist das so oft passiert? Ja, weil wir gerade bei den Baumbart waren. Bei Baumbart. Und dann schaltet er zu Baumbart und er liegt so auf dem Boden. Und Orks haben ihm die Beine abgehackt. Und alle Zuschauer so, warum zeichnet das nicht? Und der Bildmischer so, scheiße, scheiße, scheiße, scheiße, wo ist Mary, wo ist Mary? Wir machen das Mary, der in so einer Gletscherspalt hängt und so, fuck it, drop the credits, Howard Shaw, komm, spiel, spiel irgendwas, spiel irgendwas, ich hab nur Ed Sheeran, ja dann den. Wir machen das nie wieder live. Wir haben die ersten zwei Filme live gemacht, fuck it, den dritten, das muss ich morgen drehen. Man schaltet den falschen Zeitpunkt weg. Finde ich eine gute Idee. Das ist ein bisschen so ein Metahumor, wie das Douglas Adams macht in seinem Buch, was ich immer, also in den ganzen Per-Anach-Durch-Galaxis-Büchern, wo er ab und zu so ein bisschen die Luft rausnimmt. Da gibt es so eine krasse Action-Szene, wie alle Charaktere durch Luft geworfen werden,
und dann gibt es so einen Satz zwischendurch, aber keine Angst, allen Protagonisten wird in diesem Moment nichts passieren. Und dann wieder, und das Raumschiff flog durch das Universum. Genial, das ist so cool. Ja, das ist schon eine gute Idee, ja. Aber keine Angst, es geht weiter im nächsten Buch. Aber keine Angst, ausser einer Prellung wird niemandem etwas passieren. Ja, genau. Und dann wieder, und dann merkt man halt, wie absurd Actionsequenzen sind, was für eine hochgehaltene Spannung. Natürlich wird niemandem was passieren. Keine Angst, das ist nur eine dramaturgische Szene, damit so ein bisschen Action reinkommt. Damit jemand so ein bisschen frisch in den Wind reinkommt. Genau, aber ansonsten wird das überhaupt keine Auswirkungen auf die Handlung haben. Und zurück zum Laserschwertkampf Lichtwert fuhr durch die Luft.
Ja, auch alles Vokabular wird dann albern. Ja.
Weil ich meine, diese aufgedrängte
Spannung. Es schmetterte,
es schmetterte. Ja. Es zerschellte
an der Wand, es brummte. Ja, nobody cares.
In der letzten Sekunde wich sie dem...
Das ist auch so die klassische
Entwicklung. Am Anfang schaust du den Film und guckst
dir nur Helms Klamm an und irgendwann guckst du dir nur noch die anderen Sachen an.
So schaust du dann nur noch die Gefährten, weil da die besten Szenen drin sind und nicht mehr die Action-Szenen. Ganz ehrlich, ich bin ehrlich gesagt bei, spätestens bei Rückkehr des Königs, immer an dem Punkt, wo ich keinen Bock mehr auf beinerlichen Kackfrodo habe. und dann immer so kurz die Färbelinung annehmen und dann denke ich muss das jetzt durchhalten.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich muss Sport machen. Das muss ich jetzt durchhalten. Ja, aber Frodo muss das auch durchhalten. Ja, Frodo ist so weinerlich dabei. Frodo ist so, ach, und bei denen ist immer schlechte Laune, weißt du? Ich bin wieder zurück zu Lego, dass sind Gimli, die lustige Zeit haben. Dass da nicht mal einer einen Gag macht oder so. Das habe ich mal versucht in meiner Rollenspielrunde, mal einen Gag zu machen in so einer ganz angespannten Situation, weil du bist ja immer so mega ernst und wir erleben da so krasse Abenteuer und du bist ja ständig gehetzt.
Ich habe noch nie eine Rollenspielrunde erlebt, wo alle ernst sind.
Naja, es kommt auf den Moment an, aber da waren wir so, wir hatten schon eine Nacht lang nicht geschlafen und haben irgend so eine böse Hexe verfolgt und die ganze Welt stand am Abgrund und wir sind durch so einen dunklen Wald gegangen mit irgendwelchen Monstern und allen hatten die Dorn im Gesicht und ganz schrecklich und wir mussten da ganz schnell hin und hatten keine Zeit und wir konnten diese Hexe überhaupt nur finden, weil wir ihrer Eule hinterher gefolgt sind. Awesome. Charisma. Das sind die beste Reaktionen auf einen schlechten Gag. Kann das mit einem Würfelwurf noch retten? Aber das funktioniert selten. Wo ich jetzt immer am Gleichungsding bin, war gestern kurz, habe ich überlegt, habe ich mich erwischt, was ist Charisma? Kann man nicht Charisma, weil jetzt wenn die sagen, schwarze Löcher ist übrigens einfach drei plus Pi plus zum Quadrat durch Wurzel neun gleich zwölf Joule.
Da kann man auch Charisma ausrechnen.
Das ist nämlich genauso theoretisches K-Konstrukt wie ein schwarzes Loch.
So, Charisma ist gleich.
Selbstbewusstsein mal Empathie hoch zwei.
Das ist meine These.
Und warum nicht andersrum?
Ja, das ist ja deine, das ist ja nicht meine Aufgabe mehr jetzt.
Hä? Du stellst einfach nur Formeln auf.
Niemand ist doch zu Riemann. Wo ist Aussehen da drin? Aussehen ist nicht im Charisma drin unbedingt. Ach komm. Okay. Gutes Aussehen ist null in Charisma drin. Okay, plus in Klammern Aussehen durch zwei. aus dem durch zwei.
Alles klar. Charme?
Nee, das ist ja gleich Charisma.
Charme und Charisma ist dasselbe. Also das ist Formel 1, Charme ist gleich Charisma. Was habe ich gerade gesagt? Charisma. Nee, was war die Formel? Weiß ich nicht, Nonsens. Nonsens. Billig hingeschmiert auf einem Löschpapier. Die Folge einer Fiebernacht.
Nee, ich weiß nicht. Ich finde das, glaube ich, ganz gut.
Aber du verstehst die Richtung, die ich möchte generell.
Ja.
Und das war jetzt mein erster Versuch.
Ist halt schwer zu widerlegen, deine Formel.
Ja, na ja. Vielleicht bleibt sie auch mal.
Vielleicht wirst du irgendwann bekannt sein, die Tietze-Formel, um zu berechnen, die ist Charisma.
Charisma berechnen.
Ja, von irgendeinem Wahlkandidaten kannst du dann das Charisma berechnen.
Und dann kann man das ganz ordentlich objektiv machen. Gut, Aussehen ist nicht objektiv. Empathie, wir müssen viel Spaß beim Messen von Empathie. Naja, da brauchst du halt so einen Sinn. Du brauchst diesen USB-Stick, du brauchst diesen Genius Bar USB-Stick, der kann bestimmt auch Charisma. Ja, kann ich mich da anschliessen. Ich dachte nämlich kurz, weil ich habe meinen ganzen DNA-Strang als Textdatei, kann ich das nicht mal durch dieses Ding laufen lassen? Und dann sagt es so, ja, das und das funktioniert gut, nils. Weil es ist dann so, es hat nur rechts geknackt auf meinem Ohr, der rechte Kopfhörer ging nicht mehr, und dann hat es aber ganz andere Probleme gesagt, die es auch noch hatte, nämlich die Ladebox ist nicht mehr so ganz, lädt nicht mehr richtig, die Akku ist total beschädigt. Da dachte ich mir auch so, vielleicht kommen wir Fehler, von denen ich gar nichts weiß. Ist auch geil. Und schau mal vielleicht, dass du weniger kurze Hosen trägst. So, das war die Genius Bar. Aber hast du mal versucht, deinen DNA-Code ins Spanische zu übersetzen oder so? Sind da geheime Botschaften drin? Ja, ich habe alles versucht. Anagramme. Auch so Buchstabensalat, dass du das mal in so ein Zehn-x-10-Feld drückst und dann gucken, ob da irgendwie alles versucht. Kommt da Motte vor. Diagonal Motte. Nein! Nein! Und ich bin die Mottenkönigin. Das kann sein. Vielleicht bist du die Motte von Anfang an gewesen. Ja, ich muss das mal gründen, aber wenn ihr da irgendwie, wenn ihr da draußen Insektologen seid, dann ruf mich an, gib mir a call. Weil die sind ja bestimmt auch spannende Wesen, die sind riesig, vielleicht gibt es die noch nicht so häufig in Deutschland. Und irgendwie hat die meinen, ich habe jetzt einen Gummibaum in meiner Wohnung, vielleicht hat der die reingeschleppt, habe ich auch schon gedacht. Gmibaum? Einen grossen Gummibaum. Aber, also der ist nicht aus Gummi, sondern der, das ist so ein Kautschukbaum. Genau. Und da dachte ich, vielleicht sind die da in der Erde drin, dachte ich. Und du willst das Kautschuk ernten, oder wie? Das erfahrt ihr in ein paar Folgen. Du machst jetzt dein eigenes Gummi, oder was? Du baust jetzt zu Hause eigenes Gummi an.
Ja, und dann sind ganz stolz mal so ein Gummiband. Ich bin
all in gegangen, weil Leute
backen ihr eigenes Brot,
machen ihren eigenen Kaffee, rösten
so selten, machen ihr eigenes Brot,
ihr eigenes Bier.
Ich bin der andere, ich mache mein eigenes Autoreiben.
Ich habe jetzt angefangen, ich mache mein eigenes Glas.
Also ich habe mir jetzt einen Sack Sand geholt
und werde den dann
Vielen Dank. Ich mache mein eigenes Auto rein. Ich habe jetzt angefangen, ich mache mein eigenes Glas. Also ich habe mir jetzt einen Sack Sand geholt und werde den dann gewissen Situationen aussetzen und dann Glas auch blasen. Ernten. Ernten und blasen und erhitzen. Ist das gerade kein Scheiß? Nein, klar. Mach das mal. Ich meine, ich habe Sand zu Hause. Jeder hat Sand zu Hause. Ich habe Sand zu Hause, auch wenn es knapp wird auf der Welt, wissen wir alle, Sand ist ein begehrtes Gut, dann sollten wir vielleicht auch nochmal Glas überdenken. Ob man nicht wirklich jetzt aufhören sollte, aus Sand Glas zu machen, vielleicht können wir auch aus irgendwas anderem Glas machen, was dann einfach trübe ist. Oder aus Glas wieder Sand, ja. Oder halt, dass wir dann nur noch trübes Glas haben oder sowas.
Finde ich gut. Finde ich auch gut. Überlegt das mal, haut mal rein und macht gewisse Dinge.
In der nächsten Woche. Bis nächste Woche, haut rein, wir machen den Turbo an und eben ab. Wir eben ab. Ciao, ciao, ciao. It's a Waste Reduction.